foreign
folks welcome to rational science the
only site on the internet that does
physics rationally everybody else does
irrational physics not even physics they
move Concepts around they call it
physics or mathematics or something like
that
anyways we have a great day today we're
going to be talking about place
very important subject place what is
place we don't even use the word these
days and then we're going to get to our
science critic who says that science is
like astrology
that they do predictions that's that's
what they do in his version of science
we're gonna find out if that's true and
then we're going to open up the floor
for questions comments that people made
since last time but let's begin today
with our
Extinction segment and uh yeah we had
some uh new news not old news but new
news this time around we have a new
president
we have a new emperor or whatever it's
called these days right and he was sworn
in and it's this fella here let me show
you give me a second here so I can put
them on
okay give me a second
here he goes listen to him okay
president Xi Jinping taking the oath of
office after becoming re-elected for an
unprecedented third five-year term by a
whopping what three thousand to nothing
vote now
show me
producing farting
YouTube
[Applause]
now how's that for democracy okay three
thousand does nothing
you don't even get that in basketball or
any of those games
um yeah so we have a new present but
what I liked about it what I liked about
the whole thing is this and here's a
comparison between the United States and
China okay
in the United States they swear on the
Bible
and over there in China I guess uh they
swear on the Little Red Book
they surround the Constitution you would
think that's a little more advanced than
this uh
old-fashioned thing about swearing on
the Bible I mean you know uh in fact
um I'm sure a lot of Hindus and Jews and
uh Buddhists and so on they may not
appreciate you know someone swearing on
the Bible but obviously this seems to be
the choice of the one the person who won
the election okay you would think that
maybe they would swear like the Chinese
there on you know on the Constitution I
think that would be a much better
idea I mean you could for that matter
you can swear on your mother's grave you
know you don't need the Bible but I
guess they all choose the Bible because
of tradition I don't know
okay anyways
uh here we have
my my good old buddy uh Frankie okay and
he says the following about the war in
Ukraine which is pertinent to what I'm
going to be talking about today and he
says Pope says Ukraine war fueled not
just by Russian Empire so the war in
Ukraine is driven by the interests of
several Empires and not just the
Russians Pope Francis said in an
interview right uh Francis said that the
conflict was fueled by Imperial interest
not just of the Russian Empire but of
Empires from elsewhere
okay without mentioning which ones but
we can all guess what he's talking about
and uh that that comes to what I've been
saying you know that don't choose sides
here
uh at least that's what I learned in my
life don't use sides in politics okay
don't don't go with Democrats don't go
to the Republic don't go
drink beer that day
voting day right uh why because you know
you might say well I'm an American and I
love my flag I love my country I sing
the national anthem
and that's about all you get that's you
know that's the only benefit you get you
don't get to decide you know whether
weapons will be sent to Ukraine whether
you uh sabotage uh China or you don't
get to decide any of that all you get to
decide is look up the flag say the
Pledge of Allegiance you know sing the
national anthem uh you know that kind of
thing uh that's about as far as
nationalism buys you you know
nationalism and five cents doesn't buy
you a cup of coffee okay that's my five
cents worth on it now the question is
why would the United States go gold
uh Russia into attacking Ukraine okay
because you know if you you want to be
honest there was a goading on the part
of the United States like you know
here's the chip on my shoulder I want
you to knock it off and you know Putin
came in there and knocked it off that's
essentially what happened here it's it's
two thugs you know fighting against each
other United States Empire against the
Russian Empire that's all there is here
and so why did they do that
well I'm saying that United States more
or less had no choice
neither one had choice you know it's
like a chess game you you play a chess
game this guy moves a rook and he forces
you to make a certain type of move like
assuming you're playing blacks in this
case right uh you're you're you're
forced to move in some way or the other
because of the way the other guy moved
okay it's kind of like that okay and
um
and yeah uh the United States goaded
rush into attacking Ukraine Russia is
now in this Quagmire we're losing people
and weapons and and bullets and
cannonballs whatever right and uh the
United States is also you know feeding a
lot of its uh production
military production to Ukraine to uh you
know kind of even up the score and have
them kill each other over there you know
why would the United States do something
like that what is the benefit is it for
democracy no absolutely no it has
nothing to do with the word democracy
it's got to do with the United States uh
not being to expand its Empire that's
what it's got to do on the side of the
United States on the Russian side
there's other reasons but on this side
you know in the American side it's that
the United States was forced to do this
okay because he cannot expand its Empire
unless it brings Europe under its wing
okay that's my five cents worth on that
and what's the worry well the worry is
China
because China's growing uh economically
and militarily okay
and it's it may not that it will but it
may surpass the United States it's at
least it's approaching its uh
encroaching on the power of the United
States and the United States is not
growing as fast as China is and it
worries them that if you project that
into a few more years you know they'll
be at the same level okay that's more or
less what the situation is the United
States had to do something about that
this war came in handy and they said
we'll just encroach on Russia and we'll
see what happens we'll push push push
push until something happens something
did happen
and what what happened was the United
States swallowed Europe that's what
happened and that's what I'm gonna look
at in a few minutes here but the issue
that's the context okay that's the way I
look at it
okay so um
uh here we have uh an introduction to
that comes from Miss Mrs Yellen you know
and she said the following puts it in
the right context okay she says
Washington you know uh treasury
secretary Yellen uh told the the house
there right to raise the federal debt
ceiling without conditions warning that
a default on U.S debt would cause
economic and financial collapse now keep
in mind the United States is the number
one country in the world in power and
economic as well as military power right
and what would happen if the United
States Financial system were to collapse
well that would not only affect the
United States it would affect every
other country in the world that depends
on the United States for many things
okay so that's the main issue and young
said that the failure to increase the
E31 trillion 31 trillion borrowing cap
would threaten the economic progress
that the U.S has made since the covid
pandemic uh the only option to avoid a
crushing spike in interest rates
following a default is for the U.S to
commit to pay its bills on time right
because if United States defaults well
guess uh guess what that does to the
world markets right it could be a
disaster from which no one recovers
maybe Beyond depression okay
if we don't do that and think that
there's some Shortcut around it that
will avoid economic chaos we're kidding
ourselves because not paying the
government's bills will produce economic
and financial collapse
absolutely uh I I agree with her you
know now you know both parties play
politics in these instances and uh so
they say well uh and they want to be
bribed in other words they say well if
you pass my project then I'll vote for
it you know that sort of thing so it's
like they put conditions and she said
look this should be unconditional you
know it should be unconditional you
should not uh play around with the uh
debt ceiling because if we need it we
have to create more money
and if not we might have a collapse not
only U.S collapse you're talking about a
global collapse here okay the entire U.S
Empire but uh that means that all
they're doing now is you know curing
this with monetary policy they're saying
let's just create money
what is that that's inflation in other
words they can't avoid just putting more
money into the system
and the question for you are the one
that you should be pondering is whether
they can do this eternally can we create
can the government the US government
create more dollars you know put more
money into circulation forever
you know whereas it's getting this money
is this real money or is this uh just uh
you know devaluating the uh
acquisition power of uh of the
proletarian
that's the issue okay you're you're
reducing people's salaries when you
create money
immediately okay so keep all that in
mind anyways uh
she's right here's the chart okay U.S
debt Rises irrespective of who's in the
White House you know you see the red and
blues okay and it's been rising at least
for the last 40 years and all they're
doing is just creating more money okay
so that means that the dollar today uh
has no relation to the dollar of 40
years ago and the question is can they
do this eternally and you would think I
don't know you look at that curve it
would seem like it's growing
exponentially
that means the next guy who uh
gets the White House in Congress right
uh I guess they'll go into the 40
trillion and so on I think it's just
going to continue to grow
and the question is when you do that
you know you're creating money out of
nothing
I mean you know is the United States
producing this
from its workers
or is this real
you know and obviously if you can just
put another zero on the debt at the end
you know
so three billion three trillion let's
put 30 trillion you know if you can just
put another zero in there I mean what
are you doing think about that okay all
you're doing is reducing uh the uh
acquisitive power of
um
consumers
the workers okay
so I don't know if you can do that
eternally okay so here's a little
breakdown on some of the highlights
milestones and I haven't covered them
all here but just to give you some
things that are happening or that have
been happening the last two years okay
that puts the the world situation and
the proper perspective at least from the
United States point of view and perhaps
also the Europeans I would say here okay
here it has it says uh September uh 2021
right U.S persuades Australia to cancel
40 billion submarine deal with France
and instead buy nuclear subs from the
U.S
you know the French didn't like that at
all and here here's one article that
talks about that it says Australia made
huge mistake by canceling submarine deal
French Ambassador says and says the move
caused Fury in France a stab in the back
and uh Malaysia fellow says uh could
trigger a regional nuclear arms race I
mean they're they're abandoning the uh
old-fashioned subs and they're going
into nuclear that means the Chinese are
probably going to produce more nuclear
subs in the area so it's just going to
be you know more subs and subs and subs
in there in that region okay and so the
question is
is this good for anybody I mean from one
point of view it's not good for uh
military reasons
because all you're doing is creating the
environment like like what happened
before World War one and World War II
you know these wars don't start from one
day to the next there's preparations
going on in times of
peace you know if you could call that
piece uh there's preparation people are
militarizing in quiet in silence right
and then one day something explodes says
well we got the weapons so let's go to
war and that's how it works so are we uh
in the Calm before the storm
you know okay then what happened next
well in February of uh of uh 2022 Biden
tells the world that the U.S will bring
an end to Nordstrom too if Russia
invades Ukraine
okay and this is
here you'll see good old Biden say this
okay give me a second here
listen to him
if uh if Russia invades uh that means
tanks or troops crossing the uh the the
border of Ukraine again then uh there
will be uh we there will be no longer on
North stream too we we will bring an end
to it
how would you how will you do that
exactly
since the project and control of the
project is within Germany's controls
we will uh I promise you we'll be able
to do it
okay so he promised to shut down
North stream 2 no matter what sure that
same month we have the Ukraine war guess
what happened uh well later on we'll see
uh yeah Nordstrom 2 was indeed blown up
now I
I remember how these things work uh the
other side said oh he said that we'll
blow it up and blame him you know that
that happens as well so we don't know
who really blew it up someone knows out
there but we don't okay and uh Russia's
denied the uh right to investigate the
issue I'm not even sure if that would
help in any way okay but the point is
um the prediction came true and we're
going to be talking about predictions
today anyways uh anyways then the July
just a couple months later U.S persuades
Germany to cut oil deals with Russia not
only oil but also
um uh coal and here's the an article
talking about that Germany to stop
buying Russian coal on August one oil on
December 31st okay so
um Germans don't want to buy any more
oil from the Russians or coal and that
was because the United States put a gun
to the German's head right and so it's
like you know you're part of the Empire
you you got to fall in line you know
buddy and you know even though the oil
and the coal was relatively cheap for
Germany now it's got to pay a lot more
and it depends on the U.S to feed
oil at least oil I don't know about coal
I don't think so but uh Germany reopen
some of its Minds coal mines it's got
mines here right and so uh you know just
how things change because of this
globalization this uh Global thing that
we have uh the geopolitical uh scenario
right
okay and then um in August the 22 U.S
passes the 280 billion tip law to
subsidize chip Manufacturing in U.S I
thought uh
the US was a capitalist country and now
it turns out that it's a communist
country
it subsidizes uh its so-called free
market system right it's subsidizing and
I guess other countries force it to
subsidize because they're subsidizing
their Industries so China if China
subsidizes its Industries
uh free market does not exist you know
companies over here cannot compete so
they go to the government say oh please
subsidize us as well
and the government has no choice but to
subsidize or put um in place some
tariffs or whatever right to prevent the
other side from gaining any advantage so
it's like China's forcing the United
States to be communist and not the other
way around right and yeah here's the
article the chip act okay and you'll see
it on the White House
website okay science act will lower cost
create jobs strengthen Supply chains and
counter China that that's the big deal
okay so yeah they're a little uh worried
about China getting close to the power
the might of the US government that's a
big danger right now for the US
government here it's not growing as fast
and it has this advantage in technology
which it may be eroding especially when
China has so much manufacturing over
there that's what's concerned here and
they had to as far as I'm concerned
that's what they had the big picture is
that they had to create an incident
uh and that was Ukraine
goading uh Russia to invade Ukraine why
because they care about Ukraine and
ukrainians why would they care about
ukrainians they're Russians there's no
difference between ukrainians and
Russians they eat the same nonsense uh
they they have the same language they're
the same they have same religions and
also it's all the same
uh but the issue is not to get uh
Ukraine into NATO because you know even
if it's it's an addition it's not an
important addition it was to get control
over Europe first they took England UK
out of there with this brexit and now
they're taking the rest of Europe
and as you can see they're they're
destroying some of the big Industries
like Subs right chips okay they're they
they want to have control over that
um and they're also telling the
Europeans especially the Germans to cut
ties with China economic ties you know
so that's another thing that's going on
okay it turns out they did blow up north
stream too and here's uh you probably
saw the article somewhere okay here it
is that's where they blew it up okay
North stream uh one and two pipelines
there okay
so they blew that up someone did okay we
don't know who
can't blame anyone because we don't know
and we don't even know those people who
are investigating if uh they're
investigating or uh eliminating evidence
you know that you can say whatever they
want now okay uh then that turns out the
EU also uh passed a a chip Act of its
own this comes out of the European
Parliament okay chip sack you the eu's
plan to overcome semiconductor shortage
and it goes on to say in a world facing
a crisis due to the lack of
semiconductors the European chips act
AIDS the security EU Supply by boosting
domestic production
and uh it might be a little misleading
because some of those companies you know
are American like amds are in Intel's
there okay so keep that in mind so when
they say they boost production question
is whether that helps the Europeans or
the uh American companies okay so that's
also in the background and
um
then the U.S persuades recently more
recently U.S perceives persuades
Netherlands right to stop selling
semiconductor processing machines to
China sophisticated like uh aligners
aligners are very sophisticated they're
machines that are in the photo
lithographic area of the Fab very
delicate process you put photo resist on
a waivers take a picture of it with some
very sophisticated machines they're able
to uh carve into the photoresis these
patterns and those are eventually what's
going to be etched and doped and so on
and make the device work okay and so
Netherlands uh there's a company there
and here it is asml and they're a big
important company the U.S imposed
semiconductor export controls on China
now a key EU nation is set to follow
soon and that's uh the Dutch government
is analyzing what law to implement so
that that asml does not sell some of its
top machines to China
so who does asml sell those machines to
then in the alternative and I wouldn't
uh put it past the United States buying
out asml in in the near future and again
the United States is putting
restrictions
all over Europe right now if that ain't
conquering a region well I don't know
what it is okay so keep that in mind and
then the last one here and again it's
not limited to the there's other things
going on right among them that they took
rush out of the Swift system which was
how they passed uh money between Russia
and Europe that's gone right uh and it
says the latest the news says that U.S
subsidizes Volkswagen okay battery
production in us against EU protests and
this is it
um what Biden is trying to do is uh
according to his way of thinking right
is to bring manufacturing back to the US
okay and here it is Biden did it yeah
electric vehicles battery manufacturing
is coming to America says President Joe
Biden's policies appear to be having
their desired effect it should mean more
jobs and cheaper Electric vehicles for
Americans in the long run Volkswagen
Europe's biggest car maker is holding
off on plans to build a battery Factory
in Eastern Europe as it avoids Europe's
response to the incentives Biden is
offering income in companies making
batteries in America okay so the company
may decide right to prioritize a factory
in North America where it could benefit
from
10 billion dollars in subsidies now
that's uh that's a a big bribe there
right okay their European Union is
considering offering other incentives to
keep production on the continent so now
the United States is encroaching on
European economics uh through these
moves and the Europeans are not too
happy you know all these things are
happening there and they're not too
happy about some of them but it's like
you know are you on our side like uh
George Bush said well you're either with
us or you're against us so uh you got to
be with the with the Empire you know it
reminds me of the dillian league in the
days of Athens where um
we're first uh
uh the Athenians said hey let's all get
together all their friends right all the
city-states that were friends of Athens
and they formed this billion League okay
and so okay they had the deal you need
and it turns out over time it evolved
and Athens told uh the city-states look
uh don't worry about sending ships and
Men down here uh just hidden money and
we'll use our own men and ships and army
Etc and so it turns out that uh if a
city-state rebelled and said well we
don't want to just send money what do
you think we are paying tribute to
Athens
and Athens then would send the Army
against the these these tinier
city-states and say look you better pay
up Tony wants his money
so if you want to get into trouble you
had to bow down in some tribute to
Athens and Athens built at sampire so
the the Delia League was a way of
building Athenian Empire okay then he
got into trouble with Sparta but that's
a separate story okay so uh what's the
issue the issue is the United States is
a little worried because of some of the
uh facts
the realities okay here's one reality
and that's population okay this is China
us and Russia just to give a comparison
in population USA has three times two
and a half three times the population of
Russia
China has four times the population of
the U.S
there's four Chinese wherever you want
America
okay and it's like a little over 10
times the size of Russia
so that's one issue you know here they
have a lot of Manpower something that
the Russians don't have right now uh to
fight into war in over there in Ukraine
right so they're suffering with that but
uh you know if uh you the USA has to
rely on covering the map you know
especially in the in the Pacific over
there in in the region of China
the Chinese are going to make the United
States suffer with just the amount of
the volume of weapons you know submarine
ships Etc that they put on the ocean
right now I found out the other day
Chinese is the biggest
um Navy in the world I thought it was
the used to be the British right then I
thought it was the Americans but no the
Chinese are now the the country with the
most ships
and it's not going to stop I mean for a
country as big as China is and with the
extra cash that they have on hand you
can see why the United States is a
little worried about you know these
colonies out there and so it's trying to
create this uh billion League over there
with Philippines and Thailand and
Indonesian and whoever it can get in
Australia right in Japan and to see if
it can uh have some friends there in
case there is a war against China
specifically over Taiwan right and
that's one issue here's another issue
it's the growth rate you can see what's
happened at least since 1960 the green
one is China and China went up and down
was very low in the 60s it just had come
out of uh its uh World War II fighting
with Japan so it had a very lousy
economy it was uh in deep Kaka right but
quickly it gained it gained the growth
but you can see uh that overall it's
been in the tens and 15s for quite a bit
of time even up to today in the early
2000s right but since then China is
dropping a little bit and it's dropped
to five and six percent meanwhile the
United States at least uh since the 60s
has not done much better than two to
three percent in general you know a
little bit higher sometimes maybe around
five percent but that's about the
highest it's it's gotten in the last I
don't know 60 70 years and and
um you know if China keeps growing at
five to six percent in U.S only a two to
three percent well you can see that
there's got to be a problem for the
United States and uh I I just threw
these lines these are mine right so that
you could see what's happening overall
both China and the US uh are coming down
they they can't grow at five and ten
percent forever in fact the reason in
China grew so fast it was so backward
that it had no choice but to come into
the modern world but now it's almost
there and if we have it right the
Chinese uh intend or plan or project to
have a what they call modern Army or
modern uh defense Etc uh in about four
years by the year 27. so they're working
very hard on weapons you know they're
not asleep in the United States knows
that and it's Gotta look ahead and find
out what it's going to do in four years
okay if there's no war between them
there's no incident right here's the
build up of China and you can't just
sleep and let them do it uh you kind of
have to you know see what you're gonna
do and that's what all the military and
the US are thinking about you know so
everybody's moving their uh pieces on
the chessboard
and we'll see what happens but almost
sure I could almost bet that there's
going to be an incident there's always
an incident because it's to someone's
convenience okay so there will be an
incident that's that's my five cents
worth uh I'm predicting predicting here
I'll put my uh
astrologer and cap on I'm predicting
there's going to be an incident you know
one of those uh false Flags
and uh so get ready for that anyways
here's the uh
GDP share uh Global share of GDP and you
can see that what is projected is for
China to surpass the United States so
it's going to surpass the United States
if this is true right it will surpass
the United States in influence in
countries of the world uh maybe it gets
to even put the renminby the the Chinese
money instead of the dollar or push the
dollar aside a little bit right or maybe
a lot who knows but this is the
projection this is what the United
States fears exactly these Trends all
these Trends are something they watch
and they say look this is not very good
at all for us okay that's why China's in
the news lately and that's why the
United States that not Russia which got
all these icbms not Russia but China is
the enemy the the enemy to watch out for
okay
okay so uh again here's the uh GDP since
1930s uh you had that era of depression
and you have the Roosevelt uh New Deal
and then you had the award you can see
how things got really good during the
war you know we don't care about how
many people died or who died we care
about the fact that you know uh country
was growing
manufacturing was booming but then after
the war you can see how it's uh stead
there's a steady decline in the uh
percentage right uh so you know keep
this in mind this is something that uh
cannot be avoided and it's going to
happen to all countries right now one
country that's uh booming a little bit
is India
and it's it's booming because it's so
backward and so do not be mistaken you
know maybe it's the next China in the
sense that it's going to be booming the
next
couple years three four years maybe but
you know with technology they can do
that very quickly
and once they're up there then they get
into asymptotic growth when you get into
asymptotic growth
you know you're in trouble that means
it's the end of the cycle if you made
the most of it while they were growing
great for you you know as an individual
but then after that you know you get
into this asymptotic growth and
everybody's going to get into that
asymptotic growth meaning the whole
planet the the economy of man okay goes
into asymptotic growth
and the question is what happens after
that
well Bill gatie will tell you that
Extinction happens after that
okay
okay let's move on to our place segment
what is place
okay here we have uh
you know if if you're a betting man uh I
I do bets uh but very seldom very very
seldom but I like to bet at the horse
races when I do you know so but not so
much betting I go there to watch the
horses I really love to watch those
horses and uh they're great they're nice
they're
manicured okay they're they're pretty
right and uh if you go to the horse race
or those who do they probably heard the
word place okay and here's place you
have uh you bet on the first horse and
the second horse whichever the two in
other words you bet your that your horse
is going to be either in first or second
place and if he comes in any of those
two places well you uh you win right
it's usually a two buck bet okay
depending on the country
but uh no that's like the the place I'm
gonna be talking about today I'm going
to talk about another type of place it's
a place that uh the Greeks talked a lot
about and like I said earlier it's uh
it's a word that uh has gone into disuse
nobody talks about place today they talk
about position they rarely talk about
location they don't use that word either
they talk about position mathematicians
right meaning the so-called scientists
of today right they talk about position
not place
okay so where do we put Place well uh in
our Universal movie tool right here's
the tool okay and Universal movie is one
frame uh for every location of every
object in the universe right that's one
frame so each frame in that movie has
only static Concepts that you can see on
the top the yellow and blue right and at
the bottom you have this uh Bayesian uh
violet-ish
region which involves at least two
frames so the ones on the top static
Concepts they have one frame the ones on
the bottom which are Dynamic require at
least two frames to conceptualize where
do we put Place well we're going to put
it at the top we think place is a static
concept okay
uh the problem is that the that the
Greeks did not put it there okay not all
of them at least some of them did
but some of them did not
and actually I would think that more
most of them did not uh Harry did
Aristotle but so let's get into that
let's find out what what these folks did
let's start with Plato I could start
with earlier guys but we'll start with
Plato here and he says matter in space
are the same
whoa that blew my mind what do you mean
matter in space are the same but yeah
that's that's how he saw this he thought
that there is no such thing as an empty
place right he says space is eternal and
admits not of Destruction and provides a
home for all created things
and is apprehended without the help of
sense meaning touch and see right but by
kind of spurious reason
and it's hardly real whatever he meant
by Rio right he never defined the word
so we don't know what he was talking
about what he had in his mind but I
guess he was thinking about C and touch
right that's what people identify with
real which we be holding as in a dream
say of all existed that it must have
necessity be in some place and occupy a
space but that what is neither in Heaven
Nor in Earth has no existence
while two things the image and space
meaning an object and nothing right the
antithesis of it right are different
they cannot exist one of them in the
other and so be one and also two at the
same time
okay so uh they cannot be you cannot
have two words and say that they're the
same thing okay so there's there's a
there's a problem there right all things
are changing their place
I guess that's what he's referring to as
motion and things when divided do not
cease to pass through one another have
no idea what he meant there and to
change their place in other words he was
talking about motion and he saw motion
as a change of place uh the problem with
that is that the word change already
involves motion so he's using a synonym
to Define motion and therefore it's an
invalid definition it's a circular
definition it is an irrational
definition if you use the word change to
define the word motion for the purposes
of physics in ordinary speech we don't
care you can say whatever you want
okay uh then came his student his name
is Aristotle came a little later okay
and this is what area had to say and
yeah he said the physicist must have a
knowledge of place
okay you have to know what place is
about right it's important but he says
the physicist not the mathematician okay
and he meant physicist he made a
distinction between physics and
Mathematics
as well as of the infinite
okay now we get into Infinite okay and
not only infinite he's going to get into
um uh what continuity means in other
what does continuous mean for the
purposes of Faith he's going to get into
that as well namely whether there is
such a thing or not and the manner of
its existence and what it is both
because things which exist
are somewhere
he didn't know what he said there things
which exist are somewhere he said
existence is object plus location
but the problem is no one ever used this
definition even him he didn't realize
what he said there but he said it there
that that is the definition of existence
things which are somewhere
okay so he said it but he said in
different words and he never picked up
on that neither did anyone else no one
ever uses including Aristotle okay so he
said it but he didn't he didn't mean it
the non-existent is nowhere the question
what is Place presents many difficulties
moreover we have inherited nothing from
previous thinkers
I say the same thing we've invented
nothing I have no shoulders to stand
upon as Newton said once no Giants
okay uh so what did uh let's go first
with continuous because that's an
important point in his argument this is
what Arie had to say about it he says
nature a principle of motion and change
and again they equated motion with
change as we saw last week but the
important thing here is he says infant
is often used in definitions of what the
continuous
uh no
continuous means that an object is made
of a single piece that's what continues
means in physics for the purpose is a
fizzy but he's talking about math
that's what he's talking about he said
the number line you know numbers are
infinite meaning one right after another
not infinite in the sense of physical
physicality you know it's not a physical
entity that he's talking about he's
talking about a concept he's saying you
can count because that's what a number
is counting You Can Count incessantly
and we cannot imagine where the end of
that is
and incessant is not the same thing as
infinite infinite is an adjective
incessant is an adverb for the purposes
of physics incessantly right how you do
something okay but anyways he says what
is infinitely divisible is continuous
absolutely not it's the opposite what is
not infinite what is not divisible
period right is uh is continues yeah but
he never picked up on that and he says
Place void and time are necessary
conditions for motion
well I agree with place and void right
uh and really avoid uh and place should
not be there either in a sense they
shouldn't since they should not okay
because we only gauge motion with
respect to objects and not with respect
to space place or void but for sure we
don't need time
it's the other way around time requires
motion motion does not require time okay
and that's because of the definitions of
these words for the purposes of physics
time required is a comparison of two
motions whereas motion is two locations
as we saw last week two locations where
do you see time
right and where do you see void where do
you see place all you need is two
locations only if you think that maybe
place is a synonym of location
which it ain't
okay
uh location is the set of distances and
not the volume that an object so-called
occupies it's not the amount of water
the fish displaces in the ocean in other
words that volume that the fish occupied
that was uh you know full of water and
now you put the fish in there and it
kind of displaces all that water that
volume there that's not the notion of
location which was the notion of place
and void that they had in their minds
okay that's what they were talking about
okay uh
so here we have this a fellow who
criticizes me and he says about that he
says if what Aristotle means merely is a
potential Infinity right then he
continuous thing is merely something
that could be broken into Parts but
isn't already
so this fellow is making a distinction
he's defending Aristotle and saying that
the potential is not the same thing as
the actual that's what he's referring to
here okay Aristotle and the pre-socratic
atomness right would agree that if there
is some physical things separating two
other things without a break or holes
right that this was continuous
yeah so listen to what he's saying right
there Aristotle would agree it is a
single piece but it is not itself Atomic
because he was complete that's if I was
comparing against the atom is like
um uh what is it the Democritus and
lucifus okay they were taught they were
atomists and they say everything's made
out of atoms so he's so we're comparing
two things here we're comparing the
ideal Cube that's made of a single piece
against things that actually exist which
are made of atoms and so the atom as
we're referring to things that exist and
these people were a little more abstract
and they were saying you know it's not
made out of anything it's not made out
of atoms because we have these Concepts
such as cube maybe you know maybe that's
what they had going through their minds
ideal geometric figures and you cannot
talk about an ideal geometric figure
made out of little particles for example
right atoms okay so um Aristotle would
agree it is a single piece but it is not
itself Atomic and could be split apart
into smaller pieces
right so we're talking about the
potential here okay however it isn't
already composed of both smaller pieces
before being broken up as the atomist
would lead you to believe yeah but we
got a problem here if it can be broken
up it means it was made of pieces
otherwise it can't be broken up
okay so uh I tend to disagree with the
gentleman uh no you cannot uh defend
Aristotle on those grounds because
whether it's potential or actual I think
is irrelevant if you can break it up it
means it was already made of pieces
otherwise you can't break it up the word
continuous means made out of a single
piece and if it's made out of a single
piece you can't break what is made out
of a single piece into pieces
okay
and that's all I can say about that
that's my take on that okay Aristotle
continues says every physical body has a
place to which it moves and rests
naturally without being forced and
before there's a natural motion is the
motion that does not require an external
cause so the way they looked at it you
know we have my famous pencils right and
the way they looked at it they said look
if this is standing still right and I
let go of it something or it itself has
uh this uh motion that does not require
an external cause and so you let go of
in and false and you say well hold it
nothing pushed it nothing pulled it
because I cannot see or touch that which
pushed or pulled this so I let go of
this and it falls down and I say well
why did it fall well because it's got
natural motion says Aristotle so there's
no cause it's just what we can't see
your touch
and so there's nothing there and so it's
got natural motion which means it just
Falls by gravity that's natural motion
okay okay but it goes to a certain place
right and then change of any kind as the
actuality of a potentiality as such as
movable or as potentiality
so he talked about you know the
potential of something that just holding
like if I hold something he has the
potential potential gravity potential
energy whatever you want to call it
right and what happened when you let go
of it that potential becomes actual
because now it goes into its motion okay
when the buildable is fully real
whatever he means by real nobody ever
defined it it is being built and this is
building in other words
buildable is potential building or in
the process of building well that's
actual so he wants to distinguish those
for some reason that was important to
him I don't know I guess it was
important because they couldn't see or
touch the gravity the mediator of
gravity and so they said well it's got
natural motion it falls by itself we
don't know why we throw it up in the air
if it falls down I didn't bring it down
but it came down
so they never figured that out they were
trying to figure out gravity I guess why
why this world works by
Blackmagic right
okay so uh essentially in in their minds
and not only in Aristotle but other
people as well like Melissa's and
um
you know some some of the other uh
iliadics Xeno Etc uh Place void vacuum
in position in space where sometimes
used as synonyms sometimes they were not
they were distinguishing place from
space
um and from void
uh like in the case of uh
Plato he says that place is like a
physical object there's no difference
between place and matter or space and
matter and they would think of void as a
place devoid of matter so that's the
void or the vacuum so it's like you know
some of them believed that it was the
same thing some of them said it's
different okay so this this is uh one
thing you got to look at one of these
grease at a time find out what each one
said but it says motion is change of
place
okay
again here's the word change in
Locomotion there he says okay and and
yeah you can't use the word change
because change already involves motion
so change in motion in this instance are
synonyms and you cannot Define a word
using a synonym
so he hasn't said anything until we know
what change means and change means
motion motion means change so we're done
uh so change of place doesn't tell us
anything what do you mean by place
says place would not have been thought
of if it had not been a special kind of
motion namely that with respect to place
yeah you move with respect to a place or
position or location
that's what he's saying and so that's
how Place comes into the definition of
motion what now contains air for merely
contained water so that clearly the
place or space there you can see that
he's kind of using them as synonyms into
which and out of which they passed with
something different from both
yeah
so uh weather replaced air and then air
replaced water as the water went by and
that's that was their notion that uh
something is always there in that place
in that space in that position right it
is impossible that what has no reference
to motion or the distinction of up and
down can be a place
okay so if if it's not related to motion
you cannot talk about Place places only
only has importance with respect to
motion that's what he was saying
okay so here we have uh different
Notions that with which he tries to
explain Aristotle tries to explain
um what place is he just gives you kind
of examples there yeah void is a place
burift of body in other words
place it has a body in it whereas when
the body leaves it leaves a void if void
means completely empty place I hope you
can understand that right so he's saying
place is like a place holder where the
body which the body occupies okay and uh
you know as long as the place holds the
body in it it's not a void but once you
pull the body out you have place and he
says that's void so now the question is
whether void and place are the same uh
without the body
okay and he's saying no without the body
Place becomes void
but that is what one some people would
say and he's not going to argue that
he's just gonna say that's what normal
people would think of uh void as being
as a place bereft of body
places something distinct from bodies
okay every sensible body is in place in
other words he's talking about again
sensible meaning I and uh and uh hands
he's talking about seed touch
and what blew me away says uh it has
three dimensions length breath and depth
so Place void space you know all these
have three dimensions and even to this
day the mathematicians talk about the
three dimensions of space
so that hasn't changed in uh what in
over 2000 years one of the problems here
is that breath and death are not
Dimensions they should never be paired
with length length width and height
are dimensions and
um death breath and elevation are
vectors
breath and death have to do with motion
length has to do with a stat is a static
concept so they never figure that out
unless the translator translated it
wrong which is something else right
because again we don't have this in
Greek we don't have the notion that
Aristotle had in the back of his mind
all we have is the translation okay but
then he goes and says place is supposed
to be something like a vessel The Vessel
being a transportable place but the
vessel is no part of the thing
so you put water in a flower pot right
you move the vessel which in this case
is the flower pot right and but the
flower pot is not part of the water that
you put in there okay that's what he's
saying
so he's he's getting these Notions ready
so that he prepares his definition okay
so here we go and he says How could a
body be carried to its own place if
place was the matter or the form
if the place is in the thing place will
have a place
okay so if a place is inside the thing
you're carrying the place together with
a thing and before you move it place
already has a place it's where the thing
is in other words the position as I call
it when water is produced from Air the
the place has been destroyed for the
resulting body is not in the same place
what sort of Destruction then is that
so he says space must be something
oh man that's a big contradiction
now again if space is something we need
to Define what do you mean by something
what do you mean by space we say that
space is not something space is nothing
the opposite of something that's what we
say in physics but he says space must be
something he said space is like a rock
no different or uh we could even add uh
general relativity and say time is also
like a rock because they've turned both
space and time into things
nor is it possible for a thing to be in
itself even incidentally for two things
with at the same time at the same time
in the same thing you know they would
both be in the same place essentially
the same thing
okay uh so what's uh era's uh summary
okay he says place is what contains that
of which it is the place
is no part of the thing
place can be left behind by the thing
and is separable okay these are the
Notions with which gives his
introduction and finally came comes up
with some kind of definition okay he
wants you to understand what he means by
place and he says the following says
there are just four things of which
place must be one
shape matter some sort of extension
between boundary surfaces and this
boundary itself if it contains no
extension over and above the bulk of the
body which comes to be in it and he said
the first he rejects the first three and
he says uh Place necessary is one of the
four which is left namely the boundary
of the containing body that's what he
says place is just as the vessel is
transportable place so place is a
non-transportable vessel
that's what he's going to say he's going
to argue essentially that places space
and space is going to treat as a
container and he's going to say the
inside uh wall or Surface of this vessel
called space that's place and it doesn't
move what moves are things inside this
ocean
okay that's that's going to be his
argument he says so when what is within
a thing which is moved is moved and
changes its place as a boat on a river
what contains plays the part of a vessel
rather than that of place
place on the other hand is rather what
is motionless so it is rather the whole
river that is placed because as a whole
it is motionless essentially he's
equating now place with space meaning
space out there you know the universe
and so he's saying space is a thing it's
it's a container of sorts and I guess
it's finite he saw it as a I guess as a
finite place I guess because they had he
had to put the gods somewhere you know
out there Mount Olympus they say well
they can't live infinity and so he he
makes space into this container he says
place is the inside surface of that
container that's where everything that's
where space stops I guess the place and
it's immovable it doesn't move what
moves are the fish inside this ocean and
so he says hence we conclude that the
innermost motionless boundary of what
contains is place the container in other
words that is place
that's his conclusion okay and uh even
to this day you know they have problems
understanding what space is they don't
use the word Place anymore they talk
about position from a mathematical point
of view space they use it only in the
concept context of geometry and also to
refer to that black stuff that's between
the Earth and the moon you know that
space whatever it is we don't care we
don't know
uh and and otherwise they go with
position which is what an ordered pair
or triplet or whatever okay so here we
have
um Newton's uh he fortunately clarified
everything for us he says I do not
Define time space and what place and
motion as being well known to all
oh that was so enlightening he uh he
really illuminated the issue for us he
says he's not going to Define place
because we all know what it is great
okay so we can't stop at Newton and none
of the other guys of his age like
Galileo or uh Descartes they they didn't
figure this out either you know they
didn't talk too much about Place uh
maybe mentioning it you know
tangentially
and so here we have uh today's notion
and it's very hard to find anything
about place because nobody talks nobody
uses that word but I found the uh stack
exchange and they discussed the
difference between place and position
which is exactly the the issue okay
that's that's what I wanted to get to
and I did find something there it says
the following a couple people uh put
their comments there position offers uh
often refers to a specific location for
which there are Geographic or other
coordinates
ordered pair GPS global positioning
system not Place system placing system
or whatever now it's positioning
position in many cases involves a
meaning of orientation like I'm in the
middle of the room facing the window so
place would be the middle of the room
and position would be facing the window
how you're oriented that was one of the
comments and essentially this is what I
conclude from what all these
mathematicians were have been doing for
2000 years right position according to
math is just an ordered pair it's how
you get there the instructions on how to
get to the treasure chest and place is
uh a word that more related to physics
and it's the volume of body occupies
okay so it's the body itself
that's essentially my conclusion on this
and uh so place in position I guess you
could say are synonyms from a physics
point of view because position is the
object itself and places the object
itself
so when a fish is in the ocean
uh it displaces water you put in the
Ocean Suddenly it displaces water the
volume at displaced in other words the
exact volume of the fish that would be
place the end position two synonyms and
the ocean would be space
okay so to speak that's that's the
notion I'm introducing here okay now I'm
saying that's what it is for the
purposes of physics that's why we do not
use the word place or position we have
no use for those two words because it's
the object itself
okay space we have a need for because we
need to explain what that black stuff is
or Define it or whatever okay and uh
location we have to Define because it
has nothing to do with space really or
with void or vacuum it's got to do with
distances from all other objects so we
make that distinction there and so here
are the conclusions for place okay
uh according to the Greeks right place
is uh void vacuum nothingness emptiness
space they're all essentially the same
sometimes sometimes they're not
depending on which Greek you talk to
okay uh places the ocean According to
Aristotle at least meaning space the
whole shebang okay but at the same time
places the volume occupied by a body
in other discussions so they go like
back and forth it's like they never get
that clear
places the volume occupied by the body
you place it the volume of water the
rubber ducky displaces and place is the
body itself in other words position what
we call position and physique we have no
use for position or place because it's
the body itself and the Greeks uh some
of them like uh Plato said plays with
the body
because there's nothing uh you know the
there's no such thing as a void that
that's what they would say okay and uh
yeah uh Parmenides also had that idea so
did uh Melissa's probably Zeno as well
that
um you know there's no such thing as an
as emptiness as void there's always
something in they probably thought of
the air that's why air was one of the
four elements because they said look I
put my hand there there's something
there apparently it's what's going into
my mouth uh when I breathe so there's no
such thing as emptiness because they
couldn't see it but they said there's
something there that we can't see that's
from the gods probably you know eat air
or ether or whatever right and so
when when water comes into this region
uh it displaces
air or it doesn't displace air if that's
was the argument but the point is there
is no such thing as emptiness there's no
such thing as void or vacuum there's
always something there okay so this was
their notion because they could figure
out there being nothing except when you
have natural motion you know when you
let go of the pencil well this is
natural motion uh nothing pushed it
nothing pulled it but the pencil fell
because it has this potential natural
motion okay
and so yeah some some said that places
filled with something it's a body of
some kind and others say no if that were
the case and place can move because if
it's a body you can move it right uh can
I move the air well apparently that's
what the wind is right so you can move
the air so if place is a body of some
kind if it's the same thing as matter
then you can move place and some have
problems with that saying what you're
moving the location itself the empty
space that the body occupied the void
whereas there's an avoid and so they
went around in circles and uh so places
uh unmovable right in some instances uh
Parmenides and meluses essentially
argued this that place itself is not
movable and that's why they concluded
that there is no such thing as change
okay you cannot change you cannot move
because
uh it's already filled
so you're not moving anything maybe when
you move you everything moves at the
same time and you know some kind of
clockwise or world the universal way
that things are just shifting around but
you're not really moving you're standing
in place and the whole universe is
moving so to speak so some had these
Notions anyways uh we can't figure out
what place is because they did go around
in circles and never figured it out for
us it's very simple today in physics we
say we don't use the word place or the
word position those are words not so
much place but yes position those are
words used by mathematicians and they're
referring to the instructions the uh
ordered pair triplet Quadra blue
whatever uh of how to get to some place
instructions on how to get there that's
position that's what a mathematician
cares about we don't care about position
because it's a site occupied by the
object itself have no use for that
concept uh what we care about is
location which has nothing to do with
empty space or void or vacuum it has to
do with distances to all other objects
the set of which is location
and then we can use location to
back Aristotle who said that if it's
somewhere then it exists and that's
pretty good on his part unfortunately he
never realized what he said
okay let's get on to our science critic
and uh apparently our science critic
uh decided to become an astrologer he
says that astrology has to do with
uh predictions prediction is the main
purpose I guess of astrology people want
to know their future or whatever so
astrology is
founded on predictions in fact that's
what the kings in the old days used to
use astrologers for to tell them what
the future is will I win in war am I
going to die you know or when or am I
going to fall in battle they want to
know the future and when the astrologer
failed
he didn't live very long
anyways um yeah he he believes that
science is also about making predictions
okay and so here's our uh astrologer our
science critic yeah I took a picture of
him and says science is like astrology
it's all about making predictions okay
so he thinks he's making uh science he's
doing science because he does
predictions that's going to be his
argument right
okay so let's uh find out
um
what he has to say listen carefully here
it goes okay and you'll see what the
questions are that we have to answer
today here goes
the questions and issues to be addressed
today include
our predictions with astrologers do
our predictions what the mathematicians
do
if yes to both questions
how are the mathematicians different
than the astral nerds
this is how astrology often operates by
making a statement that's so vague that
it's likely to come true and because of
this astrology is not considered to be
science because you cannot test
something that's so vague now before
Bill agrees with me on the basis of
astrology doesn't explain anything I'm
just going to make up an explanation
right now according to astrology your
personality can accurately be explained
by the position of stars filling up your
chakra with tiny electromagnetic ropes
as you were born I hope I didn't just
accidentally make Bill Gatey believe in
astrology there
okay uh what do I have to say about that
well let's go one thing at a time
um
uh let me get this here
um astrology he says is equal to
prediction but that he says that's also
what mathematics is about predictions so
we got a problem there first thing I
want to answer him is that he confuses
physics with philosophy a lot of people
make that error people ask why is there
something rather than nothing
that's an idiotic question has nothing
at all to do with physics and it is not
a question of physics it's a question of
philosophy philosophy deals with
purposes and reasons and physics deals
with causes and mechanisms and when
people ask those kinds of questions they
don't realize they're asking a question
of philosophy in the in in the guise of
physics okay that's what's happening
robes have to do with physics and
behavior why you are like you are has to
do with philosophy and so to say well uh
what did he say there that uh because I
was born under a certain chakra that
I've got these robes connected to me and
because of that I am the way I am uh no
uh in in that sense he's totally wrong
why I am like I am has little to do with
the ropes okay uh from another planet or
whatever
okay so what's the issue so he says
um
astrology eight science because the
prediction is vague and can't be proven
allegedly or supposedly by an experiment
right that's what he's got in in his
mind so how do you prove that a particle
can be in two places at once okay I mean
if if you're going to make a prediction
say I'm going to predict that a particle
can be at two places at once oh yeah
that's a vague
untestable prediction
okay because you say okay there the
particles are two places at once well
that's your explanation please draw it
and so the guy draws two particles and
he said those are two particles not one
okay so you can't say that a particle is
at two places at once because what
you're showing on the screen is two
particles
so how do you prove that two particles
can be how do you prove your your
prediction
I mean you you showed what it is but
your explanation is irrational because
you cannot even illustrate it all you
can illustrate is two particles not one
okay you can illustrate two rabbits not
one so the part the rabbits at two
places at once no I see two rabbits uh
they're twins they're siamese twins
right I mean what are we talking about
here and how do you prove that time can
be worked
time is a concept how do you warp a
concept
well they do in general relativity you
know they have this
net and they warp and they say see there
it is
since when do you replace do you
represent
time a concept an abstract concept with
a with a net with a fishnet and it's
like saying love we represented with a
heart oh where did you get that
I mean what is this poetry what are we
talking about here no not in physic you
don't represent love with a heart or in
any way I mean that's poetry that's
great don't don't mean this poetry real
in the same way you cannot say that
you're going to represent
uh time with a fishnet and say oh I
warped I warped time no you warped a
fishnet that I understand but you didn't
warp time because a net does not
represent time so how are you going to
approve your prediction that gravity is
the warpage of time you know or whatever
that you warp time if you cannot even
put it on the screen
what are you gonna put on the screen for
time a bunch of seconds a bunch of
minutes years what are you gonna put in
there
so yeah and who do you prove it to
the pope uh Cardinals maybe maybe uh
some Monken uh in Buddhism you know what
are you going to prove it some Authority
you you're gonna prove it in front of
God or Saint Peter I mean what the hell
is this
I mean when you talk about proving
because that's what he's saying that
it's vague and you can't prove it well
first of all it's vague because uh
they're turning Concepts into objects
that's already very vague the
explanation given for that but then it
gets worse when you say well I'm going
to prove it to an authority and he's
going to tell you Bill
well what Authority well the people over
there in Cambridge and you know in
Harvard
so who says they're Authority who gave
them the authority does it come from God
and blood from God
so yeah the problem we have with all
this is that this poor fellow he was
brainwashed in high school and college
to believe in mathematics and he just
takes it at face value because he says
well they can't all the mathematicians
on Earth can't be wrong
guess what that's all I could tell him
okay so um here we have uh what
a fella who says who who follows up on
that and says if the Rope is a physical
connection it must be something we can
detect and measure
see the the thinking of see and touch
what experiments have you done to detect
and verify the existence of these robes
yeah they want predictions and they say
Okay predict something okay I'll predict
that the pencil falls to the floor why
does it fall to the floor well because
uh every atom of the pencil is bound to
every
uh Adam on Earth by electromagnetic
ropes that's why this falls to the floor
as it falls the ropes you know fan out
and Falls faster and faster and faster
that's the acceleration of gravity we're
done
prove it bill
uh well I'm gonna try to approve it I'm
gonna google them see if I can see and
touch the ropes
is that what we're gonna do you say I
see you can't prove it well no one can
prove it no one can prove even quantum
mechanics particles I mean do you see
particles here uh falling or coming or
pushing from above
so we cannot prove
what is the media what mediates gravity
we cannot prove we cannot prove what
mediates magnetism you know here my two
little magnets right there
there they are and we cannot prove
what's in here I can't touch it or see
it no matter how much I try but
apparently the two magnets recognize
each other because they say oh I love
that guy
and if it's
you know opposite poles as they say uh
then they push each other away why
because they're going counterclockwise
uh versus counterclockwise or clockwise
versus clockwise that's why it's got to
do with clockwise and counterclockwise
rotation of something and not with
positive and negative but see all these
people just learn these things by Road
in high school and they never they never
challenge it they just swallow it
because look at all technology we have
and technology has nothing at all to do
with science science is about explaining
technology is about developing gadgets
by trial and error one thing has nothing
to do with the other
so so these people say well we have all
this technology therefore that proves
that all the theories are correct and
what are the theories about other
predictions
astrology
but astrology is not science because
astrology is vague and it can't be
proven and science is uh
what is science
predictions
vague that can't be proven I guess we're
in the same boat so yeah this guy is
saying that astrology is science
scientists like astrology and there are
no there's no difference between them
okay let's go with some of the questions
and
comments people made since last time
here we have one phone he says physics
is causes and mechanisms whereas
philosophy is purposes and reasons
absolutely I said that he's he's just
reinforcing that and it says an example
of physics would be what caused the
Soviet Union to take over the Eastern
blood
absolutely not
he phrased it in terms of physics he's
talking about philosophy and he's
phrased it in terms of physics in his
mind he thinks he did a good job he did
not
what what he's saying is for what
reasons did the Soviet Union you know
take over the Eastern Bloc he's talking
about reasons purposes not causes and
mechanisms but uh unless he gets that
right he wanted me to look at his video
I looked at it the whole video and he
wanted me to give my opinion on
philosophy but he thinks he's I guess in
his mind he's talking about physics he's
not you gotta understand that first you
know unless you understand the
difference between philosophy and
physics your question is not put in the
proper context and therefore I cannot
approach it in my instance I can tell
you the following I don't care at all
about philosophy I don't care at all
about uh psychology which was I guess
the subject he's interested in I don't
care about that stuff it's a subject
that doesn't interest me in in the least
why people behave the way they behave
you know unless it's related to physics
somehow you know like this other fellow
says the ropes
pulling uh at a given chakra you know on
your body uh from afar well maybe like
that is the only way you could say but
otherwise not interested at all
okay another fella raises another issue
says Heinz horser uh interview on what
is reality he goes into how science is
truly disconnected due to math okay
belief is the death of intelligence and
uh by this fellow Robert Wilson as soon
as One Believes a doctrine of any sword
or assumes certitude one stops thinking
about the S the aspect of existence that
aspect of existence and that is I think
quite true you know when when you know
nah many you believe right because
knowledge is certitude in belief
Justified true belief
from your point of view right so uh when
you know
uh then you don't research any further
because there's nothing more to research
you already reached the Zenith of
knowledge you know and there's nothing
more that you need to learn about that
but I looked up this guy Heinz uh
Forster and he's not a scientist he
wasn't he's already dead now but he
wasn't a scientist he's just like the
rest of them and the main thing I
disliked about what he said is that he
has this notion that so many people out
there have especially religious people
that will never be able to explain this
universe how this universe works
you know they have this notion that it's
beyond comprehension and God only knows
you know the devil or mother nature but
we humans we Petty humans we will never
figure it out
and that's where they're wrong the
reason we haven't
to date figured it out is because the
mathematicians are in charge of
so-called science and they're not doing
physical interpretations what they're
doing is math and then uh they accompany
that within the most irrational
explanation they can give you the most
irrational mechanism physical
interpretation
causes mechanisms so so this is the
problem it's not that we we're not
entire I mean if if God himself right
came down to Earth today and told us
look
I'm all powerful I'm all knowing I'm
going to tell you how this universe
works
humans would have the intelligence to
understand what God is telling them
especially I mean if if I tell someone
look this is how a car works and a car
is very complicated you have gas here it
goes into the front goes into the
carburetor into the you know the Pistons
moves the wheels I would have to explain
piece by piece and that's quite
complicated not everybody will catch it
at the first moment you sometimes you
got to take courses to understand piece
by piece right you can understand one
part today in another word part tomorrow
until you put it all together
this gravity right let's go
this
is the simplest thing on earth
this hopefully is not as complicated as
a car okay we let go and it falls to the
floor okay so here we go let go and
false now how complicated do you think
that is gravity
it's got to be the simplest thing on
earth
it's got to be baby stuff the only
problem is we can't see the mediators
and so we can't see the meteors it's
it's black magic action at a distance
but if you can see the media you say
well that's not action at a distance
it's like pulling on a donkey we all
know I mean if if you can pull on a
donkey and see the rope and see the
hands and see the donkey coming towards
you everybody would say wow stupid I
mean I know how the donkey came towards
you you pull down the road
but if you go like that and the donkey
comes towards you and you can't see the
Rope oh man you say oh action at a
distance how did the donkey approach him
he's going like that
how is he pulling on on that donkey is
it pushing is he pushing with air from
behind how's the donkey moving
and the only difference is that you
can't see the mediator that's the only
difference and that's the only problem
with gravity we can't see the meteor or
touch it
and that's what drives everybody nuts
and that's why they haven't figured out
gravity in 3000 years
talking about gravity 112 wants to know
and he says how are ropes acting to make
an object move
you say it ropes Fanning out which
mediates gravity but how does it work
exactly if you have object B between
bigger A and C more atoms right then
because C has more atoms it has more
ropes tied to B then a has to see and
therefore it pulls on it
no uh if so how do row pull on it no it
doesn't pull is itself explained it is
uh you just have to watch the picture
the movie what would be a single turn to
describe this mechanism of the row what
are they doing
it's called tension
tension according to the mathematicians
is a force
according to physics it's not
force is if you know Newton's equation
mass times acceleration means someone
wins the tug of war
Force means you push or you pull
something Moves In One Direction or the
other
tension no one wins the tug of war there
is no motion this is tension
okay maybe I can just pull this thing
out
give me a second here
this is tension
tension is a stick
now is the weight moving towards the
other way are both
growing apart no it stays there in the
same place that's tension according to
physics no one wins the tug of war in
either direction
so
it's it's a tie between push and pull so
to speak there is no motion intention
and until you understand that that takes
two years to understand there is no
motion during tension it's not a force
as it is in the religion of mathematics
okay so once you understand that then
you say well you have two atoms right uh
let's see we got here two atoms that
we have two atoms right and you have a
rope between them hold it let's see if I
can get that rope between them
okay there you have it two atoms Bound
by a rope oh ah let me get it so that
you can see it
I'll put it here there we go okay so we
have two atoms
and they're Bound by a rope okay
no one wins the tug of war
this doesn't go that way and doesn't go
that way they don't go both towards each
other they don't go fall apart it stays
the same way
okay what happens is one atom drifts
along the other right along the Rope to
the other so drift the Rope doesn't move
it's the atom that moves slides along
the like a beat on an abacus okay the
the atom is going to move okay but not
the not the Rope itself okay that's
that's the first notion that you have to
get here's the notion for Gravity so
that you can visualize it okay I'm gonna
put it up here hopefully you understand
some of it and expect you to understand
how it even though I think it's
kindergarten stuff but a lot of people
don't grasp it so here it is okay here's
the first one okay we have an uh
astronaut and when he's farther away he
only weighs 25 kilograms when he gets
closer to the Earth he gets fit he
weighs twice as a month 50 kilograms
what has changed well what has changed
is not the number of ropes the number of
ropes of his body in other words the
number of atoms of his body are one
trillion that's the number of atoms in
his body he's got one trillion atoms and
the Earth has one quadrillion atoms
right so we have one trillion atoms each
one connected to the quadrilla each of
the quadrillion atoms of the Earth
so the number of ropes the number of
atoms are fixed
okay that's reality that's that's what's
out there
now we put it in motion why is there
motion well because gravity acts and
what do we mean by gravity we mean that
as the astronaut Falls those same rows
there's not an increase in none other
robes anything like that the ropes fan
out
they're all under tension not one rope
is pulling the ropes don't pull they're
not elastic bands like like this one you
know it's not a rubber band
okay it's not an elastic the ropes
are just standing still what happens is
the
um the rose fan out as the object
approaches and the atoms also slide
along the ropes if if they're not in a
solid okay like if it were water that's
falling but keep but let's not go into
that because that's too detailed but
here we have the astronaut falling okay
here it is in real time
this is what's happening
okay
okay I hope you understand that
so all that's happening is the same
number of ropes are there but they're
Fanning out that's why an astronaut
accelerates okay
and um
let me get this out give me a second
here
okay so uh why does that happen well
here let's see if we can illustrate that
as well okay here we have what we call
an effective rope there's only one
effective rope there are five atoms and
they're all lined up together with that
atom at number six that's in the
cylinder so they're all lined up on the
same axis
so it's like there are no five atoms on
the cube it's like there's only one atom
on the cube because all the others are
in between
okay and what happens when the cylinder
approaches the cube well you can see the
ropes fan out now each atom is I'll use
the word pulling in then though there's
no pulling but it's like each atom is
acting or pulling independently there's
a tension along each one of those as if
these ropes appeared from nowhere
the ropes were there in the upper
picture
they were there but they were on the
same axis so it's like they all um uh
canceled each other out there's only
it's there's only a pool between one and
six to use the word pull there's only
tension between one and six but as the
cylinder approaches the cube the ropes
fan out and now each one acts
independently meaning that there's
tension along each one of those ropes
but each one is acting independently
which before they were not they were
acting as a single rope and there you
see it on the right two objects in space
are very far apart although the ropes
line up and they're on the same axis so
gravity is very weak but as the cylinder
and the cube approach each other you can
see what's happening to the ropes
they're Fanning out and that is uh what
we call weight
and that's what um Newton had in his
equation mass mass divided by distance
squared okay
so uh that's the theory okay that's the
explanation for Newton's equation that's
why uh you fall to Earth you jump and
suddenly you fall back why because every
atom in your body is bound is tied to
every atom on Earth
and you say well I don't feel anything
no you know you won't feel it but you
can't touch the ropes you can't see or
touch the ropes
and hopefully we can explain because if
there are no ropes then you're using
black magic
it's not the other way around you say
hey Bill you're using black magic you
know it's the other way around because I
put an object in there I put a rope what
are you going to put in their particles
and you say nothing then you're doing
black magic you're saying you fall to
Earth because nothing is pulling on you
okay so it's the other way around okay
and people think that I'm doing black
magic no it's the other way around
you're doing black magic if you don't
put an object in there you can't explain
things with action at a distance because
action at a distance is black magic
that's all you're saying you don't
explain why that's happening you just
said it does so because I move my magic
wand and say abracadabra and that's why
it's happening
that's the context
okay
um and the same fella asked another
question he has several but I just I'm
just going to answer two of them when
the second one is magnetism and he says
magnetism is the Rope dividing in two
and one of them swinging around which
then could attach to those around like
velcro Works uh no it's not like velcro
at all that's the wrong analogy okay to
begin with do rose excessively detach
and swirl uh attaching with another atom
again the attaching uh we gotta find out
what that word means okay what do we
actually mean there uh which then does
the same Etc until increasing over and
over and how do the rows work in the
reverse way they uh
um
re-tie themselves into one DNA like rope
and stop swirling what do you call this
the swirling of the Rope what's the term
for this
well uh what the the mechanism is as
follows
let's get the mechanism right okay
and let's visualize it first
here we have uh mechanism okay
you can see what's happening to the
magnets and I put the clockwise
counterclockwise there so look at the
letters there on the
Far Corners okay it's clockwise
clockwise uh that uh the rope swinging
in that direction and it's not the ropes
I'm sorry the threads okay Reds is
different than ropes what's happening is
uh when they swing in the same direction
you have a traction when they swing in
opposite direction against each other
that's when you have repulsion okay and
here's another image of that give me a
second here
move this let's put this other one in
here
okay here you see it okay
what you have is the uh aligned rows of
merged electron shells which I call
serpentines okay so these serpentines in
the first case up there they're facing
in the same direction and they're moving
counterclockwise okay so if they're
moving counterclockwise
um
when one comes out the other one comes
down they go through each other they go
through each other okay and let's make
sure we understand that but there's a a
friction at Mother Nature's level
okay there's a friction with so many of
these think of gazillions of these
threads moving around it's like you know
walls of this
just walls upon walls of upon walls in
both in opposite direction
because they're in the same direction
but as one comes up the other one comes
down so in that sense they're opposite
direction and there's this uh tenuous
friction
this constant friction going on between
those coming down those coming up and
it's this constant friction that brings
two magnets together
the more the closer they are the more
atoms that intervene the stronger is the
pull consistent with what we observe in
magnetism right so you know what's
happening is the closer they come
together
the stronger the pull and the faster
they come together
so it's a self feeding mechanism
and then opposite the on the bottom
probably easier to understand when you
have two things clashing okay here's the
same thing you have friction between
walls of threads that are swinging
around hitting each other and pushing
the two magnets away that's essentially
the mechanism that we're proposing now
what's the issue the issue is uh what is
the source of the threads well the
source of the threads
are from the Rope okay this is what's
happening okay
the threads separate from the rope and
also likely from the atoms themselves
because the remember the electron shells
are made of the same thread so they come
out of the threads out of the
electron shells or out of their own more
or less irrelevant we're just going to
explain the mechanism the mechanism is
threads go through threads but there's a
friction there and that continuous
friction is what pulls them together the
closer two objects are two magnets are
to each other the more atoms that are
intervening because now they're closer
together the the threads uh extend to a
certain degree right and the more
threads that intervene the stronger is
that friction and the close and the
faster the whole process goes and that's
why uh one magnet attracted to another
is faster and faster and faster and
faster
okay so that's the mechanism
and with that I will see you next week
next